dramatic development in Scottish
politics a 58 year old man has been
arrested this morning in connection with
an investigation into the funding and
finances of the Scottish national party
that 58 year old man is understood at
this stage to be Peter Murrell the
husband of Nicholas sturgeon who of
course has just departed as first
Minister Mr Morrill was the chief
executive of the Scottish national party
the boss essentially behind the scenes
of areas with Nicola sturgeon and a huge
figure behind the scenes in Scottish
politics and he also stood down about
two and a half weeks ago as a result of
a route about membership numbers he's
forced to stand down but there's been a
separate investigation by police
Scotland into the party's finances which
goes back a couple of years now he is
understood to be the man arrested in
custody and being questioned by
detectives from police Scotland and
we're told that officers are also
carrying out searches at a number of
addresses as part of the investigation
they can't comment any further on what's
being looked at but dramatic development
there and after really a very Torrid few
weeks for the SMP these two are seen as
the power couple weren't they for a very
for years and years and years within the
s p very much so I mean Nicholas
sturgeon of course was first Minister
for eight years her husband was a big
Power broker there they were very much a
power couple and when this investigation
into the party's finances began a couple
of years ago there were claims that he
had made a loan to the SMP in 2021 to
help them with with cash flow issues and
there was
um you know there were questions about
these these two holding such senior
positions at the same time but they are
really very much very very powerful at
the top of the party hold that thought
if you would please Conor's on the phone
for us um Connor tell us more
yeah okay this is a huge development
here in Scotland in the last few minutes
that confirmation from police Scotland
that a 58 year old man Sky News
understands is Peter Morrow the husband
of Nicola sturgeon has been arrested is
in custody
I met this very long going this year
years of Investigation into the funding
the finances of the Scottish national
party let's remember Peter Morrow was in
charge of the finances was in charge of
the funding of the biggest political
party the SMP in Scotland since 1999 he
resigned just a number of weeks ago
mired in controversy over the party
withholding its membership numbers uh
later revealed those were dwindling
membership numbers the party had lost 30
000 uh people in the last year or so but
at the same time there has been Mountain
pressure around questions around the
finances of the party uh suggestion that
Mr Murrell had given a loan to the SMP
something that Nicholas sturgeon was
questioned about a number of months ago
a loan of around a hundred thousand
pounds
um the first minister at the time Nicola
sturgeon said she didn't do anything
about that and that was a matter for her
husband at the same time there had been
questions in Scotland in recent years in
recent months around uh money 600 000
pounds or so that was raised for the
campaign for a second independent
referendum uh money that was fundraised
through the Grassroots movement to put
aside for that second vote which we now
know has not happened and it may not
happen for a while to come yet and there
have been questions about whether that
money has been spent where that money
has been spent if that money has been
spent and that is where the police have
been investigating Scotland's Crown
office the pro uh the prosecution
service here in Scotland has been
examining the facts has been trying to
uh interview members of the senior
members of the SMP but Nicola sturgeon
had been clear just a number of weeks
ago during
an interview with our political editor
Beth Rigby here on Sky News that neither
She nor her husband as far as she was
aware had been uh interviewed or
questioned at all around this well we
now have this dramatic development from
uh detectives let me read you a very
short piece of that 58 year old man
arrested today as a suspect in
connection with the ongoing
investigation into the funding and
finances of the Scottish national party
the man is in custody they say is being
questioned and these searches are being
carried out at a number of addresses as
part of the investigation we understand
that that man is Peter model those
searches well where will they be taking
place that will be where the focus turns
next will it be the home that the former
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon and her
husband Peter model share all the
outskirts of Glasgow will that be the
focus of of this inquiry will the snp's
headquarters just around the corner from
the Scottish parliament in Edinburgh
will it be raided by detectives as part
of this investigation what other
officers will be included in this this
is a very uh tough moment for the party
I think it's fair to say and it is a
huge test in just the second week of the
Premiership of the new first minister of
Scotland Hamza Yusuf who is now the
party leader he said during his initial
question and answer session when he
became the SNP leader that he wanted
more transparency in the high levels of
the SNP well that certainly seems to be
happening very very quickly as soon as
he takes charge of the party this
fast-moving investigation and we know we
understand here that Sky News that Peter
model is in custody and is being
questioned right now